European natural gas prices have fallen
for the first time below their values
before the war in Ukraine to in large
part to lower demands and improved gas
and electricity Supply in the near term
the price for a month ahead contract at
Europe's large largest Exchange in
Amsterdam was trading around 83 Euros
per megawatt hour on Thursday prices
spiked in August more than 300 Euros as
markets registered a supply shock that's
when Russia began curtailing pipeline
deliveries
Olivia Galleria is a senior Analyst at
energy aspects she joins me for more
from London Olivia welcome to the show I
want to start with gas prices what does
this mean for households and businesses
in Europe is the gas crisis in Germany
for example now ending or is an end in
sight
thanks for having me so European gas
prices have indeed Fallen sharply over
the last couple of months thanks to what
I would say a lucky combination of
factors for Europe including
unseasonably mild weather
um limit competition from China which
have helped here build stocks and
therefore have dragged prices lower
however this does not mean we should get
complacent here to be honest there are
still a lot of factors that could lead
to tight markets next winter in
particular
um and that might mean prices rise back
up again for example China is coming
back to the market with the covet
situation easing over there
industrial demand could be coming back
as well in Europe now the prices are a
little bit lower we can't rule out a
cold spell
um in the winter you know in the next
couple of months and also Europe will
need to balance next winter with a lot
less Russian gas than ever did before so
all of this could mean we're still
facing a very hard situation and even in
the longer term we also need to consider
what high prices will do to the European
industry which is something that will
have to continue to face for many years
to come
I want to ask you about another
commodity oil Vladimir Putin announcing
this week that Russia will end oil sales
to buyers who observe the price cap put
in place by the EU G7 and observed by
some Nations like Australia not exactly
a surprise but what if anything does
that mean for the country's oil revenues
will it suffer significantly because of
this or is it just sort of moot
yeah
prices are indeed
um
lower
but you know by historical standards
they are not extremely low and with for
example the price cap that has been
agreed by the G7 that you mentioned at
60 dollars per barrel that's just below
what Russian government budget have been
set for around 70 dollars per barrel for
2023 so we're not very far off from
those levels so I would say overall
prices at the moment for Russia are not
that big of a concern I think the
biggest factor to consider at the moment
is how much oil and gas is Russia able
to sell
um and to export and therefore how that
is impacting overall revenues
um if you consider for example the
European embargo on Russian oil
um with that Russia has lost its biggest
market for oil and we and many other
analysts don't think that Russia will be
able to shift all the oil that it used
to import to Europe to Asia for example
and that means losses in exports and
production and therefore revenues and
it's the same situation with gas if
anything even more so because on the gas
side you actually have some significant
infrastructural constraints that mean
that Russia cannot divert as much gas
that is used to export to Europe via
pipeline or lmg to Asia
this price cap was based on the concept
or on the idea the supposition I suppose
that Russia would not cease production
or slow down production that it could
not afford to do that is that true that
it essentially has to continue producing
at the same levels and then essentially
find ways to divert it across the global
economy
we are not seeing that happening in fact
Russian gas and oil production has
already fallen uh by uh by quite a lot
since the start of the war and we expect
it to fall even further uh in the coming
months as it loses the European market
in particular
um the problem is that once that
production is shut in it's very
difficult for Russia to get it back
because of the nature of its oil
reserves which are highly depleted old
oil fields that cannot be switched on
and off like a light switch
all right that's Livia galarati at
energy aspects thank you very much